Network executives are paid to make the tough
decisions.
And sometimes, they are also paid to make
weird and bizarre decisions, like canceling
your favorite show for no apparent reason.
If you ever thought showbusiness made sense
— well, think again.
Here's a look at the dumb reasons these TV
shows were canceled.
Police Squad!
Goals
Lots of movies are made out of TV shows, but
the three Naked Gun! movies probably mark
the first time a successful series of films
were spawned from an incredibly unpopular
TV show.
"Nice beaver!"
"Thank you, I just had it stuffed."
"Let me help you with that."
Filled with sight gags and recurring jokes,
Police Squad! starring Leslie Nielsen as Lieutenant
Frank Drebin hit the airwaves in 1982...and
was pulled after just four episodes, with
the remaining two burned off over the summer.
ABC president Tony Thomopoulos was surprisingly
frank about why people weren't tuning in.
He told a reporter that "the viewer had to
watch it to appreciate it."
That's right: Police Squad! asked that its
audience try that crazy thing where they pay
attention to what's happening on the screen.
Apparently the jokes on ABC's hit shows Happy
Days and The Love Boat were so simple they
could be understood by osmosis.
(gunshots)
Long in the tooth
Pulling in roughly three to five million viewers
per week, Longmire was A&E's most-watched
original drama ever, and was among the top
rated dramas on cable TV during its three
season run.
Yet the network canceled it anyway.
Why?
Because most of those fans were too damn old!
Yes, TV networks are pretty much only interested
in courting the key 18 to 49 demographic,
which advertisers think is the easiest group
to part from their money.
So because Longmire's audience wasn't gullible
enough, A&E canceled it.
No worries, though: the show was picked up
by Netflix, which doesn't have to worry about
advertising trends.
Too rural for primetime
During the 1969-1970 TV season, CBS chief
of programming Fred Silverman noticed that
the shows getting the best advertising rates
were ABC and NBC shows aimed at young and
hip viewers, with multicultural casts in urban
environments.
CBS's shows, on the other hand, were mostly
rural family shows.
Silverman's solution: cancel all his farm
shows and replace them with cutting edge new
city sitcoms.
Out went The Red Skelton Show, Petticoat Junction,
Green Acres, Lassie, and the Jim Nabors Hour.
Replacing them?
Honest to goodness classics, including The
Mary Tyler Moore Show, All in the Family,
Good Times, Maude, and The Bob Newhart Show.
Ratings surged among younger demographics
and Silverman's move became Hollywood legend,
known ever after as the great rural purge.
"Dynomite!"
The wrong kind of smart
For 26 years, LeVar Burton's beloved Reading
Rainbow helped kids develop a love of reading.
But in 2009, budget restrictions forced the
show's cancelation because it wasn't educating
kids in a government approved fashion.
Weird, right?
Well, it all started with the No Child Left
Behind Act.
Signed into law in 2002, it sought to establish
new educational benchmarks for American kids,
many of which would be measured with standardized
tests results.
"In that box is the bill.
I don't intend to read it all."
That's fine for quantifiable skills, but it's
hard to measure "love of reading" on a standardized
test.
So there went the funding!
But hope is not lost: thanks to an incredibly
successful Kickstarter campaign, Reading Rainbow
is poised for a 21st-century comeback.
"I am overwhelmed.
Thank you so much.
This is going to enable us to really, really,
really do a lot of good."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
canceled show you think should be brought
back...